I still think he should have had a long
conversation with Chris Bosh because
there's this soma Oh Josh Smith throws
it up and in
there's so many similarities issue Val
heartily drives let Hannah
[Applause]
and a PC so you get that half season
according to the mix and watch they are
I think eventually that's what he wants
to go to Silvertips
Jumper
baseline and this is gonna be the master
blaster reverse dunk bedtime we had give
it a lot of love
17 points it is returned cluding a
highlight dump some three-pointers and
what has been an overwhelming
performances by the Cavaliers
James fires to Smith Smith puts it up
his sixth three-pointer here are the
first true quotas designed play and it's
not who shot its what a shot they are
[Applause]
and that's great defense to I mean to me
just got to take bow and say I'm darn
good 18 points but a par Smith play
continues five on the shot clock
Smith
shot plays very well by smart okay
[Music]
possible angle shot I'm not going to
allow them to
looking back to Smith
[Applause]
is the game with 10 seconds remaining
this fourth quarter again how many
things have to go right if you found if
you don't it's one thing a guy gets an
open look good dribble handoff little
brush screen give junior a spaces that's
what that is good you want someone else
to take your challenge of guarding the
best offensive player
and this first half what a movie upon
jay-ar Smith to give the Cavs a 40-32
Lee
[Music]
we're taught to relate to them ourselves
JR Smith vomits milsat
hit the floor you see that moon as in
game plan behind by the base bar so
catheters in possession
Smith with the pump fake and the little
scoots to the left this time around in
transition the little schools to the
right
[Music]
three point one left
[Applause]
chaos Smith puts up a tray and Nelson
Smith with his first three-pointer of
the first half well beyond the arc he's
executing out of timeouts J Smith we've
seen this plenty of time now it's down
well designed play he's a big shot taken
and a big shot mate nine points off the
bench for JR smith qu quarters could put
those hayward nice-lookin i've got the
wrong color uniform get it on the steel
that's getting steel body our snitch
[Music]
let's finish the chair there is an
example of running the floor run off the
three-point line very skew up oh we got
something Cavaliers the number
Jefferson Dental the novice man Jackson
many times looks for drumming on the
high hand off on the pick-and-roll gr
Smith scores up wide open yes yeah I'll
come around to pit eight in leg what's
allowed as Janice what's its goal JR
Smith off to a good start
[Applause]
[Music]
deep in the corner against Kaminsky see
if he drives him I'm gonna pull up with
this one I'd Drive right around it spins
which way did he get all the fall back
boos what I'm gonna blender timeout
Charlotte this is using his link company
whoa jr. not fair
+3 wanna go loose that's how easily he
moves on the floor like Durant red seven
feet tall he's like a ballet dancer out
and Smith has hit another one-on-one
with Laura get into a double team good
catch by JR and fighters anyway Oh first
of all the catch and then the turn on a
ridiculous ankle and he hits it and like
you said it's not much room over there
you're still able to stay inbounds Armos
out of bounds for a second round thick
chair Smith against Porter got the angle
on a birdie at the tough little runner I
love the fact this year he's really
putting the ball in the wood important
back cut early had to give it up jay-ar
Smith's close to prize so he goes to
work again off the bounce and hits
Twitter up going to the hoop there's
moisture on the floor one just skidded
now else is back junior
fires junior where they handle the face
says take that DC didn't like what he
saw their junior game
[Applause]
dellavedova Junior Smith trying to get
some space fires away buzzer is a
two-pointer now a double-team they show
[Applause]
LeBron through the double-team and
immediately got rid of it and junior was
the intended target yep
Kyrie with a great touch pass the true
professionals got their work on their
weaknesses and make them a stranger on a
second shot clock says about Saturn as
working yourself back in the rotation JR
sniff for free pass out to Smith
launches a long he's quieting down the
crowd watch this catches it another good
contest by harasses Jackson nothing he
can do that's all over that shot and
junior knocks that one down and he put
that little home run trot and then he's
talking to the cross and fly down
[Music]
[Applause]
he went flip we were trying to work real
hard at his defense in the offseason
especially getting around Fitzgerald a
good job stepping back there knocking it
down is up pg-13 going right Adam spins
away from trouble junior corner twig
[Applause]
I've been waiting for him to get his
stroke back it's been three games in a
row how about this for money with a
defender drips all over when it counts
Jr steps up big for the Cavaliers again
if it ain't rough it ain't right
full swing unselfish play around the
world we go LeBron James behind the back
finds JR Smith a sequence for the
highlight season ticket real pistol
brunt James Hunt jr. Smith for three
no more than six quarters here at
Phillips Arena they have to rename this
arena the cutback at one with 80 57
he'll have to be better against this
very talented Raptor team well one point
the Cavaliers back on January 1st
and right now it's 39 let's see long not
able to hit so they won't be useful - so
[Applause]
is it a three or - I think it was it -
four - it's a 41-point lead James drives
on Iguodala
keeps his dribbles along the face line
back up top Smith from way outside
[Applause]
JR Smith from about 35 feet locked
winland downs LeBron James showing that
passing ability finding jr. Smith who
steps in rhythm that's a tough shot
seven pertains here on the point mass
goes to Tristan Thompson JR sits on a
lunch habit and a foul he was close to
the three-point line they call it a
three they'll review it four-point plays
JR Smith with 22 points he's six of
seven from three-point range and keeping
the Cavs hopes alive of forcing that
game six still 259 remaining
great defensive efforts that time if the
big men not going to do it the godswood
Junior Couture two stars they are little
good job of attacking gamblers of 9 of 9
since LeBron got the heave-ho
[Applause]
all the way to the basket for position
as well as the big one
Jim size up McLemore pretty good
defender behind the back keep shakin
let's take a tough shot that he's got in
left 79 64 beautiful diamond chain is
probably the best passer from the pocket
from that position there on the foul
level in the lead Center but he gives up
a bunch of size LeBron backs it down
Kevin level out there junior hand in the
face just like he likes it hey Mikey he
likes that behind it 41:37 junior sneaks
behind the screen play nice pass to
cross-court good showing up to the
target gets found a taste changed the
whole thing in Minnesota they had some
talent some young talent and now they're
turning the talent into results its 30
word
the same day they want a yacht on Paul
Pierce's it's a couple which is a little
awkward finished by issue but gosh you
plan that gets MBA guard coming down
here for food okay who you are you can't
cover that guy by yourself come in
clarkson hood george and of course Larry
Nance Jr their average age is 27 I'm
joined now by the general manager of the
Cleveland Cavaliers
the most powerful thing you said in the
acquisition of these new players was
that the old roster felt like a long
slow death march so I would ask you at
what point you knew you needed to make
fundamental [ __ ]
daddy give it up good job extricate
himself chair backs up top
[Applause]
baby this is a move Jerry Smith lost the
defender and he starts as he sent their
dose it's West pretty go yeah I said no
I don't want to go that way back up in
not to jump it down Smith dancing with
it on Parker wild possession ends then
concludes with a teardrop keep an eye on
it now once he gets down in there you
could see the reason the Big Creek was
right there for the shot block point
guard spot right now to the anticipation
of junior Smith yes good anticipation
that junior he was waiting about that
they took off on the break so give it up
that's the perfect way to get the
fast-break going here today black shirts
and funnest bunch of scars and
looking for the n1 LeBron James couldn't
have done it any better they're gonna
quit Johnny game that's his first - what
about the three attacks again same
result looking for another that's TN one
coming off this time no hesitation fake
takes the puck nice blue soft touch but
you're Fredo just came on
[Applause]
firing from the back court and it went
swish shoot this cuz they're worried
about their layoffs three percentage
like you say just the catchable one leg
the Reedy knocks it down games thought
about a three Smith no hesitation gotta
know who you are Smith from downtown top
of the shot
[Applause]
oh my goodness Jo dares to the hoop
behind the back up and under Josh Smith
is to the hoop check-in what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content